patrick l'inter je suis professeur
associé à paris saclay l'université
versailles saint quentin et plus
particulièrement en charge de
l'entrepreneuriat étudiant
[Musique]
je m'appelle elliott pasta marinoni je
suis étudiant en troisième année de
licence de gestion
il ya eu de versailles saint quentin en
yvelines
j'écris vilain canard donc en 2016 avec
mon ami associé martin pigeon et
aujourd'hui il occupe la fonction de
directeur général
[Musique]
le canard aujourd'hui ça hein
un concept qu'on cherche a décliné en
plusieurs branches on a une branche
atelier on a une branche événementiel
qu'on appelle le club vient canard à
elliott c'est un projet particulièrement
original sur à la fois la mode mais la
mode éco responsable on a vraiment
commencé à développer une conscience éco
responsable une conscience locale avec
toute une gamme de t-shirts qui viennent
de sortir avec nos campagnes ulule de
présent qu'il ya eu beaucoup de succès
puisqu'il visait au moins une centaine
de commandes il en nombre de 300 je suis
accompagné notamment par monsieur
patrick jr qui m'aident à développer mon
projet et à le structurer
c'est intéressant de le voir mature et
petit à petit à la fois sur le logo sur
la communication sur le marketing et
réseau
ça va vraiment être de l'aide et du
coaching personnalisé lyndon de super
conseil comment sortir un nouveau
produit comment je vais le finance et
comment je devais m'appuyer aussi sur
des influenceurs dans le monde très
exigeant du surf international de
l'écoresponsabilité de l'environnement
et au fur et à mesure des choses
notamment grâce à monsieur l'inter on a
réfléchi on a brainstormer on s'est posé
des questions et aujourd'hui on en est
là